Since around 2005 malware has been used
to control compromised computers and
networks to perform malicious activities
that often lead to elicit financial and
even geopolitical gains.
In other words, whereas computers in the
past were merely targets of malware for
fun, they are now resources that malware
can take control of for profits and
gains.
Since modern malware are now used to
do real work to achieve profits and
gains, they tend to be
technically sophisticated and
utilize the latest technologies.
For example, they have utilized
popular peer to peer protocols and
applications to set up communications.
And they've used cloud computer servers
to support their activities, and they
have used the latest crypto algorithms
to perform authentication and encryption
to protect their communications
from subversion and analysis.